oui enfin vous savez je pense que le
prévient la république est beaucoup plus
réservée que le propre député en marche
parce que la réalité c'est toujours
difficile de faire un référendum
on sait très bien que les questions sont
toujours détourné et je pense qu
emmanuel macron comme gérard larcher
comme beaucoup de monde souhaite ne pas
passer par la voie du référendum
simplement sur la question et que les
albertains vu des points 11h45 gilles
10cl si vous pouvez pas dépasser ces
points de blocage mais on ira mais les
deux points de blocage qui l'a dit nous
sommes d'accord
la réduction de nombre de parlementaires
et la question du cumul des mandats
il s'agit pas de revenir le sujet il est
sur la limitation dans le temps s'il est
un sujet important parce que là c'est la
question de la démocratie et du ch aux
électrices et les électeurs et le sujet
surtout comme ça a été très bien dit
dans le reportage c'est l'ancrage
l'enracinement des députés
c'est quand même dramatique si ce n'est
dans ce pays on fait une réforme
fonctionne elle qui fera que demain on
aurait des députés godillots à la botte
du pouvoir
c'est ça la réalité d'inventer les
manuels macron c'est très important ce
point ce que la volonté d' emmanuel
macron il a vu les députés frondeurs et
donc il veut des députés godillots à la
botte qu'ils soient élus par le parti
politique et ça là on n'en veut pas
parce qu'un député il est sur un
territoire et par des sites vous dit le
référendum chiche mais est ce que ce
sera un référendum par la voix de
l'article 89 qui oblige à avoir l'accord
du parlement ou par la voix de l'article
11 qui lui permet de se passer de
l'accord du parlement vous pensez que ce
serait cette dernière se serait très
risqué je pense que ces options sera
serait très risqué je pense que agité
l'article on sait aussi un moyen de
pression sur les parlementaires en dix
ans voyez si vous voulez pas être
inutile mettez vous d'accord entre vous
on a bien compris la ficelle ce qu'on
dit simplement c'est qu'il ya des lignes
rouges et sinon j'ai sont très
importantes parce qu'on a besoin de
retrouver ce lien de confiance avec les
français